[Music]
okay so that's the that's the basic
wordle one other thing that's i i really
like about the real game is that it
shows a
keyboard uh that it shows a keyboard of
what letters
you've used and which ones match so we
can add something like that really quick
um
so i'm just gonna
keep it simple and
make another text output like this and
and have that display the keys that are
remaining
so
let's do another
verbatim text output
call it keyboard
and also i just realized one other thing
which is that we need to give we should
give some indication what these brackets
and parentheses mean so
we can do that by writing some
essentially just writing some html this
is like a p html tag
so let's just say
bracket
means that
the letter is correct and it
is
correct how about that
and another one
so parentheses x means that the letter
is
in the word
but in the wrong place
okay
so that should
yeah so saves
okay
so now
we've added that information there and
now we can add a keyboard
uh showing the remaining letters so
let's say output
keyboard
let's do render text again
and
we need all the letters so
um
i guess i'll just do it the
old-fashioned way so
letters equals
and i think
what's the best way to do this
let's just do paste
um
all right so i'm i'm making enough space
around these letters to put like a
bracket around it um
oh do i need to do that i don't need to
do that right now but i'm gonna do it
anyway
um so and then this is gonna be shifted
over a little bit
all right and
one more
okay so those are our letters that's
that's our keyboard and we're going to
use a new line between each of those
okay
um
actually let me call this keys
and
so what i'm going to do here is like is
really
basic i'm just going to do a search and
replace
so
what i need to do is
take
the letters from all of the guesses
and i need to check if each one
is in the keyboard
i'm doing this in a really simple way
i'm not gonna indicate
on the keyboard like which letters are
correct or that that you used and were
correct and which ones you know were not
correct and not in the word that's
that's how the real wordle game works in
this case i'm just going to indicate
which letters
you've used up and which ones are
remaining
so
and that's really easy so i can just
take
all of the guesses all right i can say
um
let's see
used
letters
is um
[Music]
first let's
yeah let's
paste together all of the words in all
guesses all guesses
collapse equals
that
and then we can
split that
into a character vector
again doing this you know string split
and then bracket one again like the way
did we did it before
um and then
we can say
used
letters is unique
the unique elements in that
all right so just you know we can uh
let's just try this at the console let's
just assign something to all guesses
let's say this is
you know first
second
um let's just say those were our guesses
and then we can step through here so the
used letters is
those two
words stuck together
then we split it
into the individual letters
okay and then we take the unique ones
out of there so we should not see in
this case there's two s's
and we should see those
uh one of those disappear
okay so these are all the letters that
we've used
so far
and we just need to remove those um
from this keyboard we'll just use that
we'll do that using a regular expression
so that should be that's really easy
so let's say um for
letter in
used letter in used letters
actually let me just say letter that's a
little bit simpler
um
okay keys is
and we'll do
we use sub to replace
letter
oops not in quotes
the variable letter
with an empty string
and
that's in keys
and at the end let's return keys
okay
all right let's see if it
works there's our keyboard
and that's great
so let's say i'll
it did not
do anything so that
oh you know why okay here's the problem
so this didn't work and that's because
all guesses there's no this render text
happened once but um
there's nothing
because this is a this is a reactive
object and there's nothing that's
triggering the reactivity to re-execute
because
all guesses is just a regular variable
it's not a reactive one
so if we want changes to this all
guesses
variable to
to trigger this render text to change
again
or to re-execute and then update which
keys are available
so uh
there's sort of
the correct way of doing it and then
there's this sort of there there's a
hacky shortcut we could use
and one the hacky shortcut we could use
is to use uh to have it listen to this
go button
but sort of the correct thing to do is
to look for is to look for changes
to the all guesses vector
and only and re-execute when that
changes so
um let's make all guesses a reactive
vowel
reactive
vowel which has the starting value of an
empty character string
okay and
we need to update it here
i'm going to split this into two lines
just to make it a little clearer what's
going on
so
all
guesses new
is
that but because this is a reactive
vowel we need to actually
we need to sort of we need to
invoke it like a function to get the um
the existing value out of it we can't
just we can't just access it without the
parentheses
so we're going to take the
existing value for all guesses append
the new guest onto it and we're going to
save it in this local variable called
all guess is new
and then we need to assign it back
into
um all guesses so and that the way we do
that is all guesses
parentheses
all ps is
new
and that should assign it back
and then when we
we use it down here
we'll just invoke it like a function
and because we're using this reactive
vowel
from this render text
every time this
thing changes the value here changes it
will cause the render text to re-execute
okay so let's try this again i'll
go
that totally did not work
error in compare words oh yeah here we
go
um
we need to
call it like a function there as well
all right reload
aisle
great and then saves
great and it's as you can see it's
taking the keys out of here
and gives
boom
and
that's working correctly now there's one
thing i want to mention
um
about using the reactive vowel
which is that
one thing that's happening here when we
call all guesses
is that
normally when we do this
because this is a reactive uh
reactive vowel
this render text just take we'll take a
dependency on all guesses so whenever
all guesses changes it would re-execute
so
so if you if you do this in most in many
cases
what can happen is you end up in this
sort of reactivity loop where you keep
appending something
um like
you keep appending something to all
guesses and then that causes render text
to re-execute and then it you know it
grows it again and it keeps it keeps
going over and over again
um we happen to not have that problem
here because
we're using the bind event
so the only thing that will cause this
render text to re-execute
is when the input go button is pressed
and so
when you do this bind event
on the render text or in a reactive or
observer
um it makes it so that it doesn't listen
for changes to the reactive
you know in relative invalidations of
things that are inside of this block of
code so so we're lucky in this case that
you know that we don't have to worry
about that sort of infinite loop
happening
um
if we did you know if we weren't using
the bind event
and we're just using a render text by
itself the normal way
then
we could use a function called isolate
so we could say isolate
and then that would cause this render
text to not take a reactive dependency
on that reactive vowel and we would have
to do it here
and here
so
but we don't have to because we're using
blind event
so here we go this is uh yeah this is
our
basic wordle game i mean this is the
basics of the game and
you can waste a lot of time playing it
i already have